processing data can be complicated
especially when the volume of data is
variable and even more so when the data
is streaming there's lots of it out
there and you usually need to work with
it before you can start to get some
value out of it but
how do you work with data efficiently
and how do you scale it in these videos
we're going to talk about apache beam a
flexible and open source tool for
processing data specifically it's built
to unify batch and streaming parallel
data processing let's start by talking
about why beam exists and then go
through how it works
[Music]
you may be familiar with the original
map reduce paper from back in 2004. over
the years the usage of mapreduce grew
exponentially in google but people
started running into limitations with
complex multi-stage pipelines the answer
to this was flume java which was
released as a paper around 2011.
there was also a need for accurate low
latency scaled pipelines which the mill
wheel focused on shortly after these two
technologies came together to become the
foundations for apache beam
beam is designed to allow folks the
freedom to compose highly expressive
batch or streaming pipelines with the
language of their choice and to run
those pipelines on a number of different
runners supported languages include java
python go and sql and you can also
choose the runner which is where the
pipeline will actually be executed for
these videos we'll be using google cloud
dataflow as our example runner
the flexibility of beam goes beyond
programming languages it also covers
lots of use cases you can set up
pipelines to deal with everything from
simple transportation which
mainly involves ingestion and simple
transformations all the way to creating
a continuous intelligence solution
as you can probably see portability and
scale are key parts of apache beam
so let's look deeper into how beam works
by going over pipelines and a few key
concepts
pipelines are basically the description
of how you'll be working with data
pipelines are essentially made up of one
or more data sources a collection of
transformations and then one or more
places for the data to end up this
pipeline also represents a directed
acyclic graph let's talk about some of
the core primitives that make up a
pipeline a p collection is an immutable
unordered collection of values and it
can contain a bounded or unbounded
number of elements beam uses p
collection objects as inputs and outputs
operating on them with transforms
a p transform is an operation in a
pipeline these transforms are basically
functions applied to each element of one
or more input p collections depending on
the runner multiple workers across a
cluster may execute the code in parallel
ultimately the transform produces one or
more output p collections after the
function is applied
since p transforms input and output p
collections you can chain them together
to make a pipeline
and then there's the pipeline itself the
pipeline object helps describe the
relationship between p collections and p
transforms since it can support one or
more inputs and outputs you can even
chain together pipelines to support
whatever kind of business logic you
might need
as i said before data can be tricky to
deal with these concepts might seem
pretty straightforward when looking at
batch data but streaming event data can
introduce more complexity thankfully
beam is designed to handle both batch
and streaming data processing with ease
thanks to the ability to group data
using windows
a window subdivides a peak collection by
using the timestamps of each individual
element there is multiple types of
windows that can be used to group
elements such as fixed windows or
session-based windows based on clusters
of events
it makes sense that an event probably
has a timestamp of when it happened but
that doesn't necessarily mean that's
when your data processing receives the
event
think about a mobile device that
temporarily loses connection you'll know
the timestamp of when the event happens
like the different actions a user might
take while playing a game offline
but when the device gets a connection
and sends all of those events over at
once you may see a significant
difference in the timestamps that's why
we separate event time from processing
time
if you were to use the processing time
as a window you might end up with events
in the wrong area and your groups could
be mixing up events
grouping by event time gives you the
right groups but that introduces another
question how do you know when you've
received all of the data for a window
handling late data is done with triggers
and watermarks but we'll talk about how
that works in an upcoming video
so today we covered a brief introduction
to apache beam and started to go over
some of the key concepts there's plenty
more to cover and in the next video
we'll go through an example of putting
beam to the test
if you'd like to learn more check out
the links in the description below and
as always thank you for watching
[Music]
you